Thank you for downloading under the skin
with me,
Russell brand.
Here's that bit where I start asking you
to do stuff.
Could you go a pod survey.com,
forward slash brand and fill in a
survey.
You might win some kind of voucher.
You probably won't be.
We'll feel good about yourself and
because you give us a five star review
please.
Particularly.
Well,
I mean I prefer genuine ones,
but we will take fake ones.
It helps us to glean power and may help
us to at some point get a sponsor,
but for now under the skin with Russell
brand is sponsored by me,
Russell brand.
Come and see me on my rebirth tour.
It's good stuff.
You know you're gonna.
Love it.
Particularly keen for you to come.
If you want to see me in woking on the
third of my Oxford on the 10th of May,
southport on the 23rd or may or ausberry
on the sixth of June.
What foot on the seventh of June or
skegness on the 15th of June.
If you want tickets to that,
go to Russell brand.com.
There are other data available,
but we particularly need to sell those
ones under the skin is sponsored by
Russell brand,
rebirth tour under the skin.
Have a look,
but never smelled it.
Today's guest is Adam Curtis do now.
Adam Curtis.
Have you seen hypernormalization his new
film?
Did you watch that thing better leg?
Did you see the power of nightmares?
Did you see century of the self,
the Mayfair set?
I've seen all them things and that is
why a much more clever than what you are
in this episode of under the skin.
I talked to Adam about what all manner
of things actually,
but he's a brilliant political mind.
If you want to understand what's going
on in the boat,
trump,
brexit,
terrorism,
the way that media news narratives or
contrived conspiracy theories,
what their value,
then you could do a lot worse than to
watch Adam courtesies films.
I've become friends with him actually,
and I find them to be an absolute
darling man.
Do you know?
You may not know that he was actually
made films for that life and that if
you're a person that's about my age who
were born in the seventies or eighties,
you meant protocol.
That's life of restaurants and where she
would get sort of like,
you know,
good news type stories like a dog.
Don't start talking.
The same sausage is sort of pap
mindlessness,
what Adam coast made that,
but he went on to be one of the great
narrators of our complex media age.
If you're an American listener and not
familiar of Adam's work,
you want to get familiar with it right
now by checking out his blog.
But,
uh,
he's a fantastic storyteller on great
sort of cultural events such as a
leaner,
like defining events such as nine slash
11,
the grip of the Berlin Wall coming down
and it gives us an interesting
perspective there.
Check out his stuff.
Check out this interview,
remember to go and give me a nice
positive review.
You're listened to Russell brand under
the skin.
I've been giving you your intro the
whole time that you've been shambling
through the corridor.
It's like a gray ghost laundry like
Jacob Marley,
with the chains being your own archive,
saying most wonderful things about
hypernormalization.
What do you mean that we're living in an
unreal world as some sort of simulate?
What do you mean by it?
What is the point of this film?
Hypernormalization.
Tell us what you mean.
What I remember happening,
I mean it's done.
What I meant by hypernormalisation is
that it got the term comes from a guy
rather than just guy who write about
what it was like to live in the Soviet
Union.
That late in the middle of the 19 eight
is where the Soviet Union was collapsing
because it wasn't really any protest at
the time,
but what he pointed out he is that
everyone knew that everything was not
right.
They knew that those in control had no
control.
They knew that those running the
economy,
we're not in control,
that everything was corrupt and often
completely faked because the leaders
were pretending they were in control.
Everybody knew this and the leaders knew
that.
Everybody knew this,
but nobody did anything about it because
there was nothing else.
It was normal and he coined the phrase
hypernormalization to describe this,
but somehow you knew that everything was
a bit odd and a bit unreal and often
fake,
but because there was no other picture
of the world and you were so within this
system,
you accepted it as normal and just went
on and what I'm trying to argue in this
room is not in any way.
We're like the Soviet Union were a very
different society,
but what we do share with that time is a
sense among a lot of people that things
are a bit odd,
an unreal and sometimes fake and those
in charge know that they're not in
charge and they know that.
We know they're not in charge of things,
that everything is a bit chaotic,
uncertain.
We distrust everyone in charge.
We also know those in charge allow a
great deal of corruption to carry on
without doing much about it.
We know that they're not in control of
their economy and they know we're not in
control.
They know that.
We know they're not in control of the
economy and in that's,
but at the same time we.
We are so much a part of that system
that we don't have any vision of an
alternative,
and I include by that the left,
the people who argue that they do want
to change things,
they don't have a vision of an
alternative.
So we accepted as normal.
So when you,
when you see another newspaper article
coming out saying,
Oh look,
they were actually supplying arms to the
Yemen to allow the Saudis to bomb Yemen.
We go,
yeah,
well we sort of expect.
Yeah man,
I know what you mean because I did hear
that we were supplying arms to the
Saudis to bomb Yemen.
They have a day on a four.
Oh yes.
That's it.
A very good example.
The reaction is the most interesting
thing of our time.
We sort of expected the,
the,
the arms industry and the government in
this country would allegedly allow arms
to be supplied to this war that we know
is causing horrific civilian deaths and
we have no way of controlling it.
We know that and we just accepted it's
normal,
but actually it's wrong,
isn't it?
But we know that however much we feel it
might be wrong,
nothing's going to change.
Is it a condition of five?
Normalization then Adam impotence.
It is impotence in the face of a chaotic
world.
We think that was in charge.
I have no control over,
but we accept it.
So it's not just impotent,
it's we're passive and we accepted.
So in a way we are as complicit in it as
our leaders,
but but we do that because no one has
gives us any alternative.
We accept it as just normal.
When the thing,
when you have an alternative,
you can see suddenly something.
It puts it in perspective.
You've got an alternative,
you see,
you see things truly for what they are,
and you can pull back,
detach and go,
I don't like that this is better or you
don't.
At the moment there isn't an.
I think one of the great faults lies
with the left who say they do one
change.
I mean the real changing moment is
coming from a strange,
weird mixture of right wing nationalism
and racism as far as I can see.
Yes,
but they're failing to offer any
alternative.
Yes.
Alternative visions is that what you're
saying is that the alternative visions
are always going to come from the
periphery or from the subculture and
that the left is unable to provide a
legitimate and genuine alternative.
There are in fact involved in it
rhetorical exchange.
Now it feels more and more like
rhetoric.
I mean,
I.
I point out in the film how strange it
is that in the recent years,
all the attempts to change the world
radically,
which had a great deal of force behind
them.
The occupy movement,
the Arab spring and tire square in
particular in Egypt,
seretse in Europe,
all of stalled.
They had great power behind them.
They had great goodwill behind them and
they stalled and I argue in the film,
it's because they confuse process with
content that they did.
They they assembled.
They were very powerful.
They had a great slogan behind them in
the occupy movement,
great deal of emotional goodwill from
people who would not normally support
revolutionary movements and they just
stopped.
So what I said that sounds.
There's two things.
One,
it tells us the,
the,
the bleak observation one can make is
that there is no coherent,
clear alternative vision,
but the other thing is that there is a
desire for change.
That's the positive thing that we can
draw from that,
that when all put their mouse or
whatever rises up in those cases from,
I suppose I'm more close to there,
to the left,
if not a traditional leftist movement
because it's embracing technology and
sort of populism.
In some ways it seems novel if not
entirely new.
Uh,
there,
there is a genuine appetite for it.
Yes.
What do you imagine Adam is the,
what,
what is the problem that,
what I mean in a way,
why
would we expect if the world is changing
as radically as it is,
if it's a result of technology and sort
of a racing or rapidly advancing
economic realities that are conventional
and traditional left would be the
answer.
Why would we imagine that?
I mean,
in a sense,
these are centuries old ideas that have
not been modified it because we're no
longer living in a version of 20th
century capitalism are we.
So why would like so why would a 20th
century socialism be a response to it?
In a way,
I argue in the film where I try and
demonstrate journalistically in the film
that we know we're not living in the old
idea of capitalism than we used to think
about.
What we've shifted into is a a new
system of power,
which I see as being fundamentally
managerial.
It's the reverse new bureaucracies
around us,
including things on the Internet,
but also in finance and in and in
management systems in all the closest
that many people work in.
The aim is to essentially keep the world
staple.
I mean that's what finance is desperate
to do it.
It's always wanting to monitor the
world.
Looking for risk.
Risk is a fascinating word.
I,
I.
This is Oregon.
I did a word search on Lexisnexis,
which is the cuttings filed of all
newspapers up until about 1988,
1990.
The word risk hardly features in German,
so obviously there and then suddenly in
the nineties it rises up and it's this
what drives modern managerial
capitalism.
If you can give it a word like that is
this desire to avoid instability,
to analyze the past,
look for patterns that are happening now
that looked like dangers in the past and
then adjust that.
There's always a sort of a right thing
to be,
and I.
I see it in our own personalities as
well.
There's always a right way to be
psychologically.
There's always a right body mass index
to have.
There is always the right stable thing
to be understand.
Now I'm going to insert for like first
availity.
One can place conservatism keep things
the way they are.
Stop things from changing over that
necessarily mean conservative in the
conventional political conservative
party.
I mean don't let things change and for
risk,
the tool that's being used to preserve
this basis it fear is a synonym.
So the fear is being used.
Fear of change.
Yes,
that's it's very deep.
Not just within the conservative
mindset,
but also within the liberal mindset in
our society is fear of change.
Look what happens when you try and
change things.
They point to Iraq for example.
Look what happens when you try and
change a country.
They point to nature and they say,
look what happens when you try and
change an ecosystem.
You can never tell the consequences of
it.
And then they point back and they go,
well,
look what you try and do with the
Russian revolution.
Look what happened there.
So you always have this constant being
blind.
Look what you tried to do the,
Oh no,
I'm sorry,
but what they ignore is the fact that
you live in a society that comes out of
a revolution which has got fantastic and
wonderful freedoms at it.
It we had a revolution in this country.
It can be good,
but it can be dangerous at the moment.
We live in a static world where were
absolutely terrified of all change.
Whereas someone like me would argue is
the change can be dangerous,
but can also be thrilling.
Yes,
of course.
No,
Someone like he would argue that.
Now,
what I think is very interesting about
what you're saying Mr Curtis is that,
um,
is that when I listened to the arguments
that can be sort of rather complex on
the things I very much enjoyed about
your films,
is there the accessibility and the
populism probably coming from your
inaugural sausages,
the movie in which a deluxe says
sausages or seems to because Mr Darcy,
she revealed to me that the man
manipulates the docs larynx.
So the,
they'll probably wouldn't have said so.
I suggest if left alone long enough.
Well,
I think what is the ultimate resource if
all of these things,
and don't be afraid of a little bit of
comedy,
Adam Curtis,
is that a little pal?
Allow the GNOMIC peculiar presence,
the Elfin presence of mischief to be
present in the room.
Allow a tender law to,
to advance up your thigh high school,
the on pondering whether you use comedy
as a way of defense.
I use it as a means for attack as a
matter of fact.
So what,
what I was saying is,
is that all of these things come from
the personal.
But when you talk about keep things
like,
because one of the themes of your ipad
normalization is we're saying,
oh well,
who's like,
you know,
the politicians aren't powerful.
That's one of the great tropes of our
age.
It doesn't matter if you switch out
cameron for Theresa May or indeed
anybody,
because there's a self seems to be some
self regulating system that asserts
stability regardless of what a opposing
force a place in this way.
Now we're like,
Ooh.
Then is a certain.
There's power.
Where is this power upon which we can't
get any purchase that evidently isn't
the political establishment as we
understand it.
Where is this power actually situated?
Would you say?
It's as simple as that.
You know,
follow the money is the great economic
interests.
Global economic interest.
This is a good place to start as any.
I think it's
John bureaucracies are grown up which
are intimately related to our politics
like finance.
I mean,
the interesting thing about the 19
eighties is everyone thinks that
Thatcher Reagan really were successful.
But actually if you look back and
increasingly historians looking back and
go,
no,
they weren't they,
they came in saying they're going to
regenerate industry.
But by about 1986,
87,
most of the industry is in Britain and
America had collapsed because of the
economic experiment.
So what factor and Reagan did was they
said they turned to finance and they
said,
can you help us?
I mean this is effectually what
happened.
And what finance did said is,
well,
we'll lend the money.
Wages weren't going up,
wages.
We're actually collapsing at that point.
So what happened is you had a switch and
they gave power to finance and finance
came in an introduced the idea of
lending on a much grander scale.
And the politicians allowed that because
they facilitated all sorts of new acts
of parliament
that allowed for that to happen.
So what you've got is a shift away from
the idea that you are on a constant
travelator have increased wages,
increased security in the industries you
worked in,
the,
your income stagnated.
And it was supplemented by lending
money.
So finance,
for example,
I've got a great deal of power now.
Underlying finance is a deep desire to
keep the world stable,
to avoid chaotic situations.
So we began to move into that world
where we're always trying to avoid risk.
What then that happens is that that idea
begins to spread out,
not just literally in terms of you
lending money,
but the idea avoiding risk becomes a
central thing in our society and I would
argue that we've all become terrified of
change.
I.
One of the things that I've sort of.
She's conservative,
yes,
of course,
of course.
One of the things I've intuited,
but not yet fully articulate it because
I imagine it's rather complex and have a
tendency to be a bit sort of a ad hoc
shoot from the hip of spit from the lip
ask questions later.
Type of a character is that Qa chaos and
their use of chaos is required.
That there's this sense in me that the
induction of chaos will be beneficial
when looking at this sort of
contemporary politics.
I've felt as you have articulated and
from my own experience with the truth
and one of the reasons I was very keen
to have you as a guest as a matter of
fact,
that is of course like a sort of like
waist deep in like the political
discourse,
get an ed miliband round the flat and
interviewing him and sort of being very
outspoken in what became a very
combatative.
And uh,
what I want to say dialect it kind of
difficult exchange with Britain's media
particularly,
is that I felt like this is really hard
to get any traction.
It felt.
I felt very quickly myered,
you know,
and like being around like the political
class.
It will be briefly around Ed miliband
and the cheeks.
It felt like this doesn't seem like it.
It felt like a very sort of a kind of
jangly and neurotic sort of Coterie of
people I didn't think like,
oh,
this is the advancement of power.
And then from being the recipient of the
kind of,
um,
uh,
sort of,
what I would say a curtailing of
managing forces from the media.
That was interesting as well.
It felt like it's so interesting to
become the subject of such negativity,
not only from sort of established media
but from people in general because when
you talk about change,
when you talk about chaos,
when you talk about letting you know,
like people like it's very interesting
like what I felt like he's like in the
story of the emperor's new clothes is
like that.
In the end you'd say that kid just shut
up.
Stop saying that about the emperor
parades like the in the.
And people get angry to let people get
angry with you.
If you say something like,
right,
doesn't make any difference who you vote
for,
you'll get the same political system
anyway.
People know that's true and they know
it's wrong.
And so they become angry with in this
case me for saying it instead of like
sort of thinking,
well bloody hell that is a pain in the
ass.
But that's reality that that's true.
Or you know,
so.
So what,
you know now I find myself interested in
sort of bigger and broader topics like
you know,
both historically and sort of a,
I know historically history.
I think what is likely to be the next
transition given that you know,
liking your film hypernormalization and
like you've just said,
it seems that the political world is at
least a once removed narrative that
doesn't seem to respond to protests,
doesn't seem to respond to activism.
It merely absorbs,
it digests seretse,
presumably pajamas.
It can handle the occupy movement and as
you've said in a in hypernormalization
than in other aspects of your work that
people that have got an established
idea,
which usually comes from religion,
like the,
the,
the Muslim Brotherhood in Egypt.
When people can go,
look,
we have got an idea.
It's this,
it's fundamentalist Islam.
That those,
those ideas are more potent and
powerful.
What do you think that we can learn from
that with take from that,
but you see,
I think that why it doesn't have any
traction change.
It's our fault as much as them.
You can't just blame the politicians.
It's us as well.
One of the great,
enormous changes of our time is the rise
of individualism is the.
It started really in the 19 seventies in
modern terms and it's this idea that you
and I believe that what we want and what
we think and what we feel is the only
authentic thing and we shouldn't be told
what to do by people.
It's really strong.
It's really powerful and it's it,
it.
Mrs Dutcher was on the coat tails of it.
Punk movement was on the coat tails of
it.
It was.
It's really it.
It dominates our society and the problem
for politics of the rise of
individualism is that it can't deal with
it.
Politics requires you to say to people
as a political party,
come with me,
join with us together and we will use
that collective power to change the
world.
But to do that you have to accept that
you're part of something.
You have to surrender yourself to
something.
And for the radical movements,
that was a disaster,
but more than that,
it was a disaster for politics generally
because political parties understand
fell away.
So what?
Then politicians there.
Let me finish what politicians being
aggressive.
Jeremy Paxman no,
this is.
This is important thing,
which I don't think because it's not
just the politicians.
What they were then faced by is the fact
that they didn't have mass support,
so they couldn't do the main thing that
mass democratic politics rose up to do,
which is to be your representative,
your bridgehead into power.
Because we had become like scurrying
little piglet.
It's going all over the world and not
have become a Skyrim piglet.
I've been a strident cantaloupe and not
joining together to form a collective
action.
I understand that.
Now what?
There's one thing I wanted to pick up on
that.
When you say something that Adam.
This is a popular podcast,
right?
So when me say something like the rise
of individualism,
what you're,
what you're saying is that like,
you know,
I think we can all say that I primarily
my worldview comes from,
but I'm me,
I'm Russell,
I want this.
I don't like that.
I've got.
Right.
So I've got feelings now like in that
that's something that people haven't
really examined individualism as a
component and a sort of an unavoidable
evolution of a mechanistic worldview and
of materialism.
Now we're like,
what are you saying?
Like when they became chronic or more
noticeable in the seventies,
so my assumption would be then that
these conditions of individualism is a
side effect of marketing of liked,
but the reason why is it convenient for
people to see themselves primarily as
individuals because that's how people
really are better.
No,
it's not a side effect of marketing
marketing comes in to make it work.
Individualism comes basically out of the
hippie movement,
the counterculture movement to the 19
sixties where you were encouraged to be
authentic by responding to yourself.
That was the idea and it was a reaction
against what was seen as conformity and
it was a reaction against old style of
politics where you were told what to do.
It was just,
I want to do what I want to be.
You know?
It was just that.
That's what happened and it was about
finding the authentic self.
Yes,
but that was a
the defined as much as anything else,
bites,
cohesion and bias,
this pursuit of civil,
civil liberties.
These were people that were were like a
lot of change came out of that.
On a,
on a civil rights level in the United
States,
right?
That's absolutely true,
but that didn't come out of the hippie
movement,
the civil rights movement,
which is incredibly important movement.
In the 19 fifties in the 19 sixties,
white activists and black activists
joined together and they spent years
giving their lives and many cases
literally up to try and change the
world,
which they did and they surrender
themselves to that.
Out of that civil rights movement came
what was called the new left and the new
left said,
well,
if we can do this for civil rights,
we can do this for everything.
And then the movement stalled somewhere
in the mid 19 sixties because what began
to happen was I knew what was called
counterculture rose up and the counter
culture was different for the new left
because what the counterculture said
was,
you're never going to check all the man
the power.
You haven't got the power to do it.
The way to do it is to change yourself.
It was the rise.
It was the.
It was the sign of a new individualists
and it didn't want to be part of it.
Didn't want to go down to the south and
spend years at an anonymity in danger,
trying to change the world.
It wanted to change.
Here.
I don't want to go down to south New
York named Ian Danger.
If I might say say you are an arch
example of hyper individualism of our
time.
I find that I'm going to write that down
or look out when I get in.
All your responses are characteristic of
exactly what I'm describing.
So what then happened is that the,
the the argument shifted away from the
idea of saying we can work together to
change the world to saying no,
if we can actually be be the vanguard of
changing ourselves as people.
Then you change the Saatchi like that.
You change the people first and then
society will transform and that sort of
work for a bit,
but then bit by bit the politics moved
away and you are left with this idea.
You just transform yourself and you have
all these radical psychotherapy
movements of the 19 seventies come up,
which is you need to find your authentic
feelings.
That became the goal and the idea that
you actually changed his society as a
byproduct began to disappear,
and what then happened was that this
strange thing began to emerge is if you
are going to be a self expressive
individual,
which was the ultimate goal,
where you're authentically expressing
yourself,
how'd you do it?
Because actually not many people knew or
had the confidence to do that,
and I argued in a series of films I made
that that really what happened was the
modern consumer capitalism said,
we can help you do that.
We can actually supply you with lots of
different things to allow you to express
yourself from ranges of cost ranges of
close to all sorts of products that you
can use to express your individual
identity.
Which was fantastic for consumer
capitalism because they could make lots
more different things.
Yes,
but you're not saying then that consumer
is like that.
You're saying that the consumer is in
mass market culture was a response to
that need?
Yes.
That's interesting.
I like because I'm,
as you know,
a fan of the films of century of the
Self,
which doesn't qualify me to know more
about them.
In the new [inaudible] you've made those
films but like what it means,
but what how I see,
I said,
look,
on one level we're deal the source
material for all of this is human beings
feeling so even when you say something
like,
I'm an arch example of individualism.
For me that means that I'm closer to to
the precipice of breaking through to
realizing the limitations of
individualism and what the implications
of the individualism is.
Limits are which is transcendence.
What happens when one,
once more transcends willingly and with
volition through the limitations of
individualism and back to a communal
experience and back to a cohesive
experience as a member of a tribe have a
community of a society.
Experiences that are somewhat the night
as a pathway to somewhat being dug up.
It's not so.
It's no longer clear what is the
direction for people that feel this
yearning and feel the limitations of our
experience of individuals of forever
living in our head,
of living,
in our anxieties of not knowing what is
real because we are living in a very
limited version of what is real,
the fulfillment of our base drives and
base desires.
That's a limited experience of being
human.
Who Will,
who,
oh,
anthropologically history historically
are designed to live communally
connected as a harmonious part of a
group in a harmonious part of nature.
And what's interesting for me about what
you sit there,
Adam,
is the.
I've always regarded the consumerism and
mass market culture,
uh,
has recognized all right,
there's this need in people that can be
fulfilled through selling them stuff.
But by you know,
by your own unique ipad,
ipad,
Ipod,
by your own unique torn jeans,
participate in culture and expressive
individualism for consuming.
But I suppose what we've not yet gotten
to is the,
the architecture of these concepts if
phenomena.
Like,
do you think there's someone behind it
designing this or,
or some interests.
Because like when you're saying these
bureaucracies are organizing this state
system stability,
like the financial bureaucracy,
you know,
who benefits from this,
who benefits from people seeing
themselves primarily as individuals
because it certainly isn't the people of
the Yemen and it certainly isn't us as
individuals.
So who is it that's preventing change
from happening?
Yes,
of course.
Ask because we can say we're not
participating in a,
in a,
in a like a potent movement because one
doesn't seem to currently exist,
but what is the.
What is.
Why is this idea continuing to dominate?
I think the point is depart consumer
capitalism is capitalism is not a.
there's nothing inherently evil thing.
It's a,
it's a moral.
It will always spot an opportunity and
it will go for it.
And what it spotted in the late 19
seventies that were there were these
people rising up who wanted to be
themselves and they realize that that
allowed you to make lots of a much wider
range of products that you have
previously done before and people went
for it and that allowed capitalism to
make lots more money and become much
more.
You know,
you saw those adverts in the 19
eighties,
19 nineties,
express yourself,
be yourself through Nike.
Just do it exactly because I'm worth.
It was the great phrase,
but then what happened was I think a
great shift happened,
which we haven't fully recognized,
which is of what I'm trying to get out
of the film is that is the genius of
modern power,
is that it managed to do what politics
failed to do.
Politics can't deal with individualism
because how can you have a political
party where everyone wants to be an
individual and not be part of something?
What modern manager or system has
managed to do with square the circle?
Look at modern social media.
It manages to allow you to feel that you
are totally yourself expressing yourself
online,
typing it angrily or beautifully or
whatever you want to do out into the,
into the Internet what you feel or the
time yet at the same time,
what you are as a component and a series
of very complex circuits that is looking
at you.
Doing that and saying,
I'm on.
If he's doing that,
then he's very much like these people
over here,
which we've categorized like that,
so we can say back to that person in the
circuit.
If you're doing that,
would you like this as well?
And you go,
whew.
All right,
because it's a bit like what you've just
done and it makes you sort of feel
secure within your individuality.
So what they've finished to do
increasingly in the modern systems of
management is except your individualism
and your expressiveness allow you to
feel that you're being more and more
expressive.
Where's the same time managing you
quietly,
unhappily,
so you become part of a very large
group.
That university because you are just the
little components and the circuit,
but the computers look at you and go,
oh,
well there's about 300 million of those
sort of types.
We're putting them in that group and I'm
not a conspiracy.
It's not a group of people going,
Oh,
we'll do this.
It's a system that can see from the
information that it's reading from you
and lots of other people,
the patterns that you are part of and
saying,
well,
we'll fit them all together into that
pattern.
Absolutely.
So sort of complex interlocks,
taxonomies that designed ultimately to
go,
if you like this,
your property,
that it's benign in terms the.
If you talk to the tech utopians from
from Silicon Valley,
they will go,
this is incredibly efficient and they're
right.
It's an incredibly efficient way of
managing the problem that politicians
can't manage,
which is our individuality and our
desire to be self expressive.
It's problem is,
is that it's fundamentally conservative
because it's feeding back to you more of
what it knows you like or things will
change.
Yeah,
but it sounded like a bit like
Christianity in a way offered a kind of
have a peg around personal interaction
with Christ.
Your own person or salvation Christ
loves you as an individual.
Yes.
You could argue that modern
protestantism especially was again,
another way of trying to deal with the
growing desire for individuality,
which has been going on since the
renaissance or before the enlightenment
decide.
Did you want to be yourself?
So question to some said,
no,
you don't have to be what Catholicism
says is just part of something you're
told to do.
You can have a personal relationship to
God and there is a very important posh
academic book written back in the early
part of the 20th century which argues,
but my uncle Max Faber that argues that
protestantism and the idea that you have
a personal relationship to God was one
of the great motor forces that allowed
capitalism to come up because if you can
actually achieve a relationship through
your own actions with God and achieve
salvation,
then you can actually say what?
I can achieve all sorts of things myself
in the here and now before I dive,
which may save me for when I die.
So it actually made you more of a heroic
figure.
Protestantism certainly that advances
the idea of individualism used their
sort of star of your own life accruing
goods and services so that when you and
when you die,
you will,
you will be a good person and you will
go to heaven and that gave capitalism
this idea that it was a fundamentally
good thing to try and achieve you where
we will work,
and you'll see this in the 19th century
novels where they depict great
capitalists.
They see themselves as heroic figures
who are not only helping the world,
but they're saving themselves.
Yes,
I suppose in a way don't we have to get
beyond the kind of a journalistic
judgment so of like ideas like
capitalism,
socialism or any individual is either
good or bad sort of is it that we need
to sort of look up functionally what's
occurring or like this seems to have
very positive results.
This seems to very detrimental results
and when you're talking about this
online collation and people put together
into 300 million man or woman hurts,
that can be marketed to and as you say,
it's benign.
These things,
not this not happening in a vacuum is
there is like,
so when you're talking to these that
that is the exertion and that's the ex,
that's the exercising of power.
We're witnessing witnessing there,
Adam,
that's not happening sort of in a
arbitrary and natural light because the
people's interests are being represented
through those resources.
Facebook is not neutral.
One of the things that I'm sort of
learning about because you know,
I'm going to university,
she very kindly wrote me my reference
which have not yet seen and I would like
to see because I want to know what kinds
of things you said about me and sweet
and adorable,
sweet and adorable students.
I hope that I'm right now looking at the
context you're using that in.
It makes me think that you fought sweet
and adorable.
It was patronizing which,
uh,
I suppose in a way it is,
but it's also being nice is patronizing.
Then I'm patronizing.
So in one of the things I'm learning
about in that Adam Curtis is a,
like the way that secularism.
And just so for those of you that were
new listener to this type of podcast,
the division of Church and state,
that division of political interest and
religious interest has always posed as I
neutral force like addicts,
expansionism and interventionism has
been justified by that we can go over to
Iraq and stick our origin because we are
a secular society,
a neutral society,
and they're doing all sorts of Wacko
stuff with that where the government has
got a mustache and metal from that and
they need to be brought down to people
to now this a positive as neutral of a,
whether it's secularism or the sort of
cyber world is one of the ways that
power has always concealed itself by
saying this isn't power tool,
this is normal,
you know,
sort of social services,
normal markets.
So sort of a sort of a capitalism
derived from protestantism,
normal Islam not normal.
And therefore subject to regulation.
The threat someone wants to the great
the,
the sign of a great ideology is
something that doesn't look like an
ideology that you just accept as natural
and normal.
So for example,
if you talk to technological enthusiasts
or utopians from Silicon Valley,
are you talking about facebook shutting
people off into their own little echo
chambers,
but they'll say,
but it's sufficient and what they mean
by that is it works.
It's actually dealing with the problem I
was talking about of individualism and
it's allowing people to be assembled in
groups yet feel individuals and they're
absolutely right.
It is incredibly efficient.
But maybe the whole idea of efficiency
used in those terms is actually a
political ideology because what they're
saying is we constantly keep people in
this situation by reading stuff and
feeding stuff to them.
And that's conservative.
That's a conservative idea because then
people but get get,
they'd get frightened of change and if
you get frightened of change then you
are actually feeding the power.
And what I keep
on trying to point out in this film is
the real power works not just,
it doesn't work by saying you must do
this,
it works well when we are complicit
within it because we accept it as
natural.
Yes.
And we are guilty of that.
So for example,
do you remember the,
the um,
March against the war in Iraq and in
London in 2003.
I think it was about 3 million people
went on that march was terrible.
Did you go on it?
I was still on drugs to care about that
actually.
I think I did go,
but it was still on drugs to care about
it.
But the interesting thing about that
march is it was really the biggest,
probably the biggest protest march since
the suicide thing in 1956 or even
bigger.
And everyone thought that's going to
change everything.
Yeah.
And then everyone went and they had a
slogan which was not in my name,
which is again a very individualistic
like it as a slogan to you.
Well,
I'm not in my name,
you know,
but it's the wild doubt my finishing
your name I think because we've got some
more lemonade we got.
Okay.
I suppose it was an interesting slogan
of its time.
I don't know how the pomposity of it
sincerity you.
Everyone marched 3 million people march
and they were totally sincere about it.
Not In my name.
And they then went home,
all right,
it's not in your name.
And they said,
well,
that's not important.
Well,
that's exactly what what the profession
was.
You go back and the war is not in my
name.
That's not what you don't anything more
about it.
Whereas real change,
real political change would have
happened if those 3 million people had
again and again and again marched and
again and worked and given themselves to
that they might.
What I've had a chance of stopping.
The horror has now happened in Iran.
It's a bit of my Adam,
I've heard you argued before,
the stability is the enemy of change and
we are obviously participants in this
because we like,
oh,
do you know what?
I don't know if I will be going on a
million person March every day because
I've got an x box and I'm moderately
comfortable.
Isn't in fact the ingenuity of a much of
contemporary secular life is that we're
for the significant majority.
We are sustained at a comfortable level
and we can tolerate in our insular cells
of comfort the discomfort of others.
Because our empathy and altruism has
been eroded,
these impulses and instincts have long
been undernourished because they're sort
of familiar.
Communal institutions of themselves
began to disappear.
What protest becomes feeling?
Well,
it,
yes it does add him and actually that
shouldn't be to our disadvantage because
when you sort of talk about me as the
arch narcissist of our time on what I
think this means is it's like that for
all things.
Returning to the point makes my point
for me that you are the narcissist of
our time.
I did it as a passing comment.
No,
because,
um,
it's something that I'm,
I'm interested in because I actually
think it's legitimate as well as this
sort of a blip aside,
you know,
that sort of,
what is it about my,
my personal conditions and the
conditions of our time that make soaks,
that make me so infatuated with my cell
phone,
my own perceptions because in a way,
how is that different from,
you know,
really from anybody else.
It's not really,
it's more pronounced,
it's more observable.
I don't imagine that.
It's not like,
you know,
how could anyone possibly know because
no one except me knows how to be inside
my own consciousness and I'm not even
sure that I'm that convinced of how to
do it.
That my point,
my point is,
is that everything's a source is
people's negotiation with the external
world at source.
Everything is the way I feel when I'm
interfacing with a society or another
human being or a product or my own
feelings coming back to me and because I
have experienced many of the sort of the
sort of the icons of success or the
icons of consuming,
you know,
have been famous being a proper drug.
Addicts being proper,
promiscuous.
I've like seen,
oh right,
these things are not that nutritional or
that helpful is that he's helped me to
reach a point where I'm willing to
consider ideas such as being part of a
community,
you know,
and like isn't that is law.
That means surrender.
Right.
You know,
sort of like the idea of surrender comes
up again and again in a sort of
spiritual and religious ideologies that
these drives.
In fact,
it was the other one said to me like,
you know,
like a,
we've been told that freedom is freedom
to fulfill,
are trivial and petty desires,
but real freedom is freedom from our
petty and trivial desires.
But you know,
in being able to sort of by yourself an
iphone or have a Wang in a train toilet,
you know,
think of this as a kind of blissful
utopia.
But what have you just fobbed yourself
off with?
In my case,
it was a 10 pound fine.
No fear.
So serious.
Why are you being so serious today?
What I decided.
You're the funny guy,
so that doesn't matter.
We can all,
we can all be silly together.
You know,
what are the lights?
So the reason I'm using like returning
to make a serious point at that point,
that's what I was working serious is
because.
No,
no,
no.
Because you've touched on something
really important to note that there are
to calm you down.
Honestly necessary.
I consider this a form of resuscitation.
This is,
this necessary was if you were lying on
a beach now.
So we are all clever in those edits with
your archive,
but really what he needs is a cuddle
that come on.
I think I'm actually trying to show that
I don't want to be controlled by your
comedic persona.
Power of comedy is very controlling
messages.
That's what I.
my point is,
and I am as much a narcissist as you.
I want to set the agenda as well,
right?
What I want you to see that that's the
trail and what I wanted to point out was
that it's not that there is the real
kind of freedom isn't.
It's a religious one.
It's a different kind of freedom.
There are all different kinds of freedom
and the idea of freedom that we believe
in now and we believe is inevitable or
natural and natural to state is not.
It's a construction.
The version of us at the moment is a
country of freedom is a construction
because there are many others and one of
the most powerful is the very opposite,
which is a religious one which says in
whose service is perfect freedom.
Is that what the religious idea is that
the self which we worship at the moment
is actually a terrible prison.
It's a cage that you are trapped and
again,
you are an example of this in and in
what you've taught them.
A terrible presentation is that when you
give a young offenders,
when you get trapped atriox short term
desires,
it's a cage.
You've got,
you got locked acuitus.
I mean even your logically one could
imagine that the process of consuming is
this stimuli and response.
Maybe it's good to escape from that
daily grind of having to listen to your
consciousness constantly saying,
I want this.
I want this,
Which we're encouraged to believe is
liberation.
Yeah,
maybe it's not.
No,
I think you're quite right.
I mean,
when I like,
I like Eva,
I'm sort of quite pop spiritual orators
such as Eckhart Tolle will say to you
that this incessant in a narrative,
the relentless thinking,
there's no freedom in that,
you know,
in some and watched where those thoughts
take you.
Sometimes.
You know,
I sort of,
I'm,
I'm walking my dog in the field,
so everything's basically not the
reality.
This material reality is I am a man in a
field with a dog.
I mean in my head,
what's happening is,
Oh God,
what did I do that for?
This will probably go wrong.
What's going to happen?
Who are those people over there,
but I'm not trying to stick again.
He keeps bringing it back,
you know?
So that is that there is like a sort of
a self imposed tyranny to that and I
don't,
you know,
and obviously like you have just a sort
of implied capitalism or consumerism or
modern culture,
whatever the hell it is,
isn't gonna solve that.
In fact it perpetuates that would.
Because the interesting thing about time
is you're right,
people live inside their heads very much
because they're encouraged to.
They're encouraged to think that is,
that is the end point.
That's what we're heading towards.
Yeah.
But,
but actually what's going on in those
heads of things that people don't really
want to tell who all the sorts of things
theory,
learning a stout.
Because actually if you are going to be
the right kind of individually,
don't have that,
you mustn't have that and you see this
on social media at the moment.
Everyone,
the,
the politician who is going to get real
power and take us somewhere in the
future,
it's going to have to deal with the
things that are inside our cubs,
which is loneliness and fear.
I'm lonely.
Fright.
I woke up this morning.
I was so lonely.
I'm a tell you something else.
God.
I was shit scared.
It took me.
I'll give you a bloody pajamas on.
Foreign knew it was sad.
I'm lonely.
I'm understand is coming down.
Bloody wanted me.
Slippers fallen off.
That scared me.
Stepped up.
Appalled that misread his bloody things.
Maybe it will only ever and ever.
And I'll say time you have to tiger on
the box.
And frosties.
Well I was scared.
Witless.
It's great.
It's too bloody late.
Tony.
I said to you this little opportunity to
have a sip of water.
So anyway,
like what people obviously want is I say
like,
you know,
the solution to this.
There were two solutions as they,
uh,
to submit.
There's a subjugation of self self in
terms of,
you know,
because of course self is an amorphous
idea,
isn't it all.
So we're talking about the kind of self
which is this sort of relentless driven
in a narrative that the two ways I have
found,
because I've had to do this because
being serious for a while to snatch your
mantle of pompous,
pious back backpacks for 10 seconds,
I myself have had to battle quite sick
because I believe that the disease of
addiction has it its core,
a kind of circuitous self centerdness
that can only be ended well first by the
removal of the initial substance that
one identifies with,
in my case,
it was like crack and heroin at the time
I got clean.
Once those things gone,
you recognize those drives are still
present.
If you,
what is it?
And it become obsessed with food.
You become obsessed with sex,
you become obsessed with work and other
people's opinion.
And in the end,
you recognize that the only way to end
this,
the,
the torture of self obsession is for
ideas that have always been present in
spiritual and religious doctrine,
service,
connection in it.
What was that?
In his service,
we are free in whose service is perfect
freedom and whose service is perfect for
self up to something beyond yourself.
So beautiful.
Even give yourself up is an idiom that
implies that there is an output
transcendent to trajectory.
I mean the other interesting area that,
that in this is the modern ideas of love
are about satisfying yourself.
Whereas the old idea of love,
where you live,
you,
you surrender yourself to someone else
and it's thrilling but frightening
because you,
you,
you give yourself up and that kind of
love has disappeared.
It would come back.
Would you say your love for me,
it's a little bit like that.
You're a bit like a sort of a modern
archive.
Troubadour making wonderful.
I know that hypernormalisation was in
some level of dedicated to me,
it could have been called hyper Russell
brand ization cut.
This could actually remember,
I love you.
So you're quite safe.
Me,
you have like a school teacher.
So I agreed to come babysit,
not being pilloried confusing love.
Go to pitch it.
Conflict with the muppet show,
Russell,
it's already been out last week.
So
the,
I am,
look what I want to get from you is this
now what you've just said is like
someone is going to make headway in the
political sphere and you know,
and obviously like I assume on some
level that would be me.
He's got someone that will know how to
close that gap between the solipsistic
circuitry.
If self obsession,
you can't this world out here that we're
all forced to.
Like you can't put the genie back in the
bottle,
you just can't.
The individualism is here to stay.
It's,
it's,
it's part of the future.
Um,
what,
what a politician in the future who's
going to change the world will do,
is somehow allow people to still feel
they're individuals.
Yet at the same time will say if you
come together,
we can actually the world and something
extraordinary and,
and,
and it will be thrilling,
but it will also be frightening.
And take them into that world.
No one's managed to do it.
The moment what's happened is a lot of
the managerial systems have managed to
make people feel they're individuals,
but manage them.
And we've got to transcend that.
I mean,
I think it may somehow come out to the
internet in some way or another because
it's a mass communication tool.
It can create constituencies globally.
They're not defined by geography states
and old,
but at the moment the technologist,
the engineering people who dominated
applying an engineering model to an
engineering models are about feedback
and they say they constantly read you in
the past and feed more back to you.
It doesn't have to be like that,
but it needs.
What it needs is a content or a vision
of the future.
And it hasn't got one at the moment.
I'll work it out by the end of the
podcast now.
Well,
there's some of the more prosaic,
uh,
aspects of a contemporary life.
What'd you think of old Trumpkins
Pumpkin then?
What do you think?
Why is this happening?
I have a very cynical theory about
Donald Trump got one.
Well,
as us politics became more and more
deracinated and what does that mean?
Deracinated thinned out the resonated
and sort of less and less substantial
and less and less able to change things
or confidently able to change things and
power shifted away to all sorts of other
things that we were participating in.
Really what people like trump part is,
they've become,
they're not really politicians,
they're pantomime villains.
They've turned politics into a
Vaudeville.
And what will they do is they come on
stage and we go,
this is outrageous in big capitals.
This is absolutely terrible.
We packed,
we tap away on social media saying this
is really,
really,
really bad.
And as I say in the film,
uh,
a marketeer for online.
So every once angry people clickable and
clicks are gold dust.
And really what those cliques do is feed
modern power and everything stays the
same.
And do you mean feed modern power
editor?
But if you,
if,
if you click a lot,
yeah,
you're actually,
that's what social,
those who run social media benefit from,
you're actually keeping the whole thing
churning over everything.
There's a lot of power in that world.
If you have something like facebook,
which in its newsfeeds increasingly
gives you what it knows you like and
what you you and what and what you hear
is what you like.
Then that's incredibly powerful because
it's actually people's reality because
you are shaping what they know and
you're shaping a Bible.
What you don't know.
Now,
those who run social media,
we'll say this is efficient.
They're not.
They're not ideologists.
They're not saying,
we must tell them this,
and in fact it's the algorithms that are
doing that.
Of course they've designed the
algorithms,
but the algorithms function is to give
you more of what it knows you like
because that's efficient,
but look at what that means.
That means that you only know what
others like you know,
and then there's another group over
there who know what they know that the
others in their group now and they never
meet.
I mean,
there's a fascinating quote of the day
after Brexit from a social media
activist who was a remainer.
He wanted to remain it,
but he wanted to find out what the other
lot felt like who were the triumphant
that day,
and he went onto facebook and he tried
to find through the custom feeds,
people like that he couldn't do it and
he was actually shocked.
I won't read you the whole quote,
but it's.
It's absolutely fascinating.
It's a man realizing that there are two
halves of the world now,
so separated from each other.
That one half can't actually actively go
and find out what the other half is
feeling now.
That's called power.
Now,
I don't think that in facebook there is
anyone saying,
this is the world we want.
They're saying this is efficient,
but that,
look what that efficiency is.
It's a conservative world that holds
things stable and implicitly.
What that means is that things aren't
going to change,
and what that means is that those who
are in remain making power,
so power,
power cannot move,
cannot move.
Revolution is about reordering,
reorganizing power,
distribution of power,
redistribution of resources,
so a powerful forces for stacy's,
however,
a anodyne they may present themselves as
being,
if not benign,
then then they are in fact the agents.
All the establishment.
Yes,
and then also in those chambers,
anyone in those in your little network
or big network who comes along and says
something that the others don't like,
gets up silently,
ejected immediately.
The book that that journalist John
Ronson wrote about what it's like being
shamed on social media is a very good
sort of anthropological example of what
happens to people within the network who
say the wrong thing.
It's like being in a village in the
medieval times,
you're just ejected if you're the wrong
person,
you're thrown out of the out of town
after the city limits,
so,
so everyone's.
Everyone remains,
remains thinking the same and that's
conservative.
We're complicit in it.
And what's an everyone?
Everyone knows it.
They know it.
One of the things that I'm very much
interested in,
you've said this several times and
there's a bit in my standup of like
talking about the morning of the cameras
election and he gives that speech and it
will.
The thing that struck me on a personal
level actually,
because the speech that he gives,
the speech that Theresa may gave,
like the speech that you often hear
politicians give,
is kind of utopian.
We're,
we're going to build a Britain where
people are prepared to work and we get
the opportunities they need with the
most vulnerable members of society are
looked after we at what your religion or
your race is.
You'll be taken care of.
We'll be able to case you've Britain
where everyone can participate.
You think fucking know if that what you
were saying,
then it was the reality that will be
okay,
but I know that what you're saying is
bullshit and you know that it's bullshit
and you know that we know it's bullshit
and yet it's perpetuated.
Now for me,
this is the distillation of
hypernormalisation is the disjunct.
Now this other idea of there being two,
a tandem narratives concurrently running
takes place,
doesn't it?
You don't need to consult the external
world to get ratification of that,
but it has because it happens internally
as well on individual levels of any
individual's consciousness.
That one census,
there's the part of the part of me that
is married to the fulfillment of my
stimulation.
There's the part of me that goes,
well,
that will just happily use this podcast
as.
Right,
okay.
Then what is another way that I can
assert myself in the public conversation
and in public life powerfully?
How can I get?
Because you know,
like I've tried sort of vanilla fame of
being sort of Hollywood actor and I've
had this sort of like this activism,
feynman that weren't quite fulfilling.
What's the next version?
Proper religious,
spiritual devotion.
Now that will,
that will do it.
There is a lot,
you know,
so these things don't.
In a way the stimuli is the same.
You know,
the object is shifting in Hollywood
fame,
money,
drugs,
sex.
The object is shifting,
but the drive remains the same.
Now it's only through like know was only
through a kind of a sense of actual
detachment,
relinquishing and service,
but I can alter the kind of,
I don't know the modem,
I can know I can alter the engine burst
or if there is such a thing as an
essential self beyond the biochemical
drives,
beyond the biographical recollections,
if there is some self is consciousness
is something and not nothing,
not some inadvertent byproduct of the
working of the mind,
the brain rather then then there is
surely some value in this info in
attaching to.
This is quite simple and religious idea.
I do think that the one thing that's
going to come back onto the table,
his religion,
because I think the real weakness of the
modern systems of managing us as
individuals is that it cannot deal with
our own mortality because the great.
I mean I'm more,
what's the word?
PROZAC and functional.
Then you have Arabic religion,
but I do think it's.
It's main function in society has been
to give people constellation in the face
of their own death that the sense that
that when they die,
something will go on and they will be
part of something that's going on.
It's really powerful and it's really
necessary and that's the in the modern,
rational,
efficient,
utilitarian,
technocratic world of managing the
individual.
It cannot give you any constellation and
I think a lot of the pessimism that you
find on the left is from that they're
actually projecting onto the world.
They're saying there's not really as
good day everybody's going to die and it
becomes this sort of terrible,
terrible fear of death,
which then colors everything which then
stops them being optimistic about
changing the world.
So That's interesting.
And when you said before about fear and
loneliness,
these,
again,
these are sort of a.
that's an emotional conversation that,
that they're kind of a dry creaking
arguments of socialism and unable to
have now.
Like I,
I think about this also often remember
that socialism came out of religion,
especially in this country.
I recognize that it was sort of
certainly departed from it because,
you know,
for understandable reasons around dogma
and because of the,
you know,
sort of necessity or lifestyle for the
revolutions of a century or so ago meant
that,
you know,
that that kind of state church and state
power had to be dressed and harmonized
and somewhat knew it.
But for me,
what that,
what is required is a sort of a,
um,
I used to once again distill and
recognize what the function of religion
actually is to help us deal with the
experience of being a human being that
you know,
that politics is no longer able to do
and no longer aspires to do and which
consumers in artfully done for the
previous 50 years.
But it seems to be filtering at this
point.
And now you're saying that these sorts,
of course we're talking about kind of a
niche market really aren't because most
of the world don't sit around on
facebook.
Are they not in like Africa or uh,
you know,
sort of Latin America?
Are they,
I don't know.
I'm not there,
but like so,
so like you know,
what we're discussing is a is a
particular phenomena to our kind of
cultures,
but it seems,
but I obviously agree with you and in
fact,
even when I was somewhat directly
involved in the media and political
conversation,
my,
what I felt was this isn't actually all.
That's what I've found.
I thought I felt like this isn't the
conversation I want to after.
This is the new shy and Trivia.
I'm interested in something that is very
direct and very real among and
understand a person like what?
What can you sort of think that all
saints get?
Not the band science and although they
were bloody good.
I'm very true.
I loved those sisters reached the point
of altruism.
Service.
Surrender becomes sort of kind of simple
and almost indistinguishable from mental
illness in it.
A lot of cases I'm talking particularly
if Francis of Assisi who wouldn't want
around your calf,
Adam,
bringing goats in,
ranting and raving,
playing the pan pipes on the stairwells,
meddling with your cats,
putting them all in jumpers and telling
you that,
that the spirit of Jesus in them.
Because let me tell you,
that's what he would do.
And like so,
like,
so this hypernormalization I suppose
what it's doing is,
is we're living in a spectacle and
anyway,
it's just,
it's too,
now that the words come up,
it's pretty similar to some of that deep
boys idea though,
that sort of late,
uh,
late 60 situation is in French situation
isn't.
I'm saying,
hold on a minute.
Well,
bloody hell is this.
It's not real.
And then you go,
what are you,
who are you?
What is my role in the world that we
have no access to what he's real,
but we are living in an impersonation of
reality.
I've never really got along with all
that debord stuff.
It's all men in black,
black punk music.
Talk about that sort of stuff.
I think it's more mundane than that is
that every,
every age creates its own reality.
That's what power does.
I'm in the functional Paris to tell you
a story about the world.
Our story wins.
Yes.
Because what is reality?
It's just a jumble of masses of things.
Gas,
real power is taking the reality and
shaping it.
And at the moment,
I think what you're talking about is
also is that we are becoming a bit
distrustful of the stories those empower
tell us and it's all feeling a bit Janky
and falling apart and what we're waiting
for
is another story that comes in on.
What I find it a bit odd is that
actually rather than celebrating this
moment of sort of transitioned from one
big story to another,
we're feeling so frightened rather than
actually celebrating it as a moment
where you can shape anything the way you
wanted it to be.
I think what's lurking around is not
just religion.
There are two things sitting around
waiting.
When is religion,
the other science,
the thing that no one ever talks about
the memory because scientists has got
stuck in many ways in dogma,
in sort of weird dogma,
but also because it's all about serving
the individual.
These days,
scientists spend their time getting
grants by doing research that tells us
that if you eat this,
you'll die.
Or if you do this,
it have a bad effect on your health.
And then next year I'm telling you the
opposite about that.
Here's another one that is sort of
reductive.
It's been reduced to at our
imaginations,
whereas somewhat science used to do was
tell us extraordinary things about the
world that hidden things that it could
reveal,
and this is sort of Austin was waiting
there to be rediscovered and I have this
instinct that what might happen in
answer to the sort of rather strange,
utilitarian stuckness of our time is
that someone will find a way of fusing
scientific ideas,
religious ideas to produce a certain,
I don't know,
a vision of an extraordinary world that
somehow has a logical power to it and it
will.
The science and religion will fuse and
it will.
What it will offer is a way of us still
feeling that we're individuals,
but there's another word we can go
towards.
What do you think would be the role of
traditional religions like Islam and in
in this changing world?
Islam is interesting because it,
it,
it combines an idea of individualism
with the sense of community and it's
powerful that.
I mean it's.
But again,
in the western world,
it's very difficult to discuss his lab
at the moment without getting a wave of,
of what's the word,
fear and disapproval because it's been
so demonized.
I mean it,
I'm not trying to praise Islam or,
or,
or be rude about it,
but it is fascinating religion to look
at and I think I gave you a book once
which was the history of the world told
from the Islamic perspective and when
you read it,
it just makes you look at the world
differently.
And that's what we do these days.
That's right.
Destiny disrupted.
It's fantastic book because it makes you
pull back and look at the world
differently and we just don't do that
these days.
I suppose people aren't really willing
to embrace that kind of mentality or
change unless there is some sort of
desperation typically.
And traditionally people don't like,
you know,
say like Latin revolutions in sort of a
bit off this mic.
People are concerned,
but my voice isn't as deep and booming
dominant as he me.
I'm like that,
you know,
typically revolutions happen when the
conditions are correct,
when people are galvanized.
Norml is an element of desperation,
but done.
There's always someone who comes along
crystallizes it.
I mean,
I've always been fascinated by the
Iranian revolution,
how many came along.
I mean he and,
and he managed to assemble three or four
different groups in society and somehow
gave them a common identity.
He didn't just killed off about two of
the other groups.
He's going really well and he's got,
oh,
the few execution is towards the back
end of their evolution.
A master's right.
But got up until then.
Well,
I mean,
what Romania did is he realized that
there was a whole massive group of
people who'd moved into the cities over
the last 10 years in the 19 seventies
who were really pissed off and felt
completely alone.
And he saw that group and he also saw
that there was a group of middle class
left wing activists and he put the two
together because what he did with this
lamb is he said,
no,
we can put it to the size it.
He pushed aside Islam,
especially sheer Islam,
which had always seen itself as quiet.
It wasn't going to take an active role
in the world and that was its tradition
and he did it brilliantly and he then
took power and you got rid of the middle
class activist.
He's just shot them around here.
Well,
it revolutions are brutal and
frightening and this is the thing that
one has to go back to.
If you want change,
if you really want to change the world,
you have to tackle power and when you
tackle it's quite rough and things will
get quite.
What's the word iffy and I think the
middle class is might find it a bit
difficult and I remember once having at
a thing with you when we were talking
about this,
just turning to the audience and saying,
well actually really?
You talk about revolution.
You talk about change.
Do you really wanted it?
Will change the world massively for you
or do you just want the banks to be a
little bit nicer?
Is that it?
I think,
and there was complete silence because
actually I do think at the moment in the
West people genuinely,
they're nice,
they're good,
they really want change,
but they want change that isn't really
going to disrupt the world and I'm not
sure that's really possible if you
really want to give a voice and a power
and a sense of confidence to all those
people outside the city who are feeling
lonely and uncertain and living
completely.
What's the word?
Uncertain lives have no sense of their
own confidence.
Confident Future.
You're going to have to change things
quite substantially and you're going to
have to take on really vested interest.
That's going to be quite frightening.
You got to be willing to give up
everything is it.
I think that like the difference between
a priest and a prophet,
someone explained to me was the,
uh,
the willingness to live it,
the willingness.
They were like,
yeah,
I'll sacrifice everything.
And I go back to the civil rights
movement in the 19 fifties and America
white middle class activists went to the
south and they gave up their lives for
years to do something that they thought
was morally right.
And as someone wrote the other day,
you cannot imagine that happening now.
They'd want to be telling everyone that
they're doing it.
Yeah.
Because that's how you get validated
these days as an.
You want
people to know that you're doing it,
but you're right.
Most of the heroes of the civil rights
movement,
especially with remained anonymous,
of course.
Precisely.
Now again,
what you're talking about is a I vialed
spiritual idea because that is about,
yes,
it is because it's about the
transcendence of your individualism that
you can't.
That you're not going to receive
validation from anyone in here who
surface.
We also politics.
Politics is about giving yourself up to
some,
an idea beyond yourself.
So it's religion and it's its,
its dominant idea about how you,
how you deal with a dynamic world.
At the moment,
we pretend the load is stable,
but it's not going to be.
It can't.
Now,
and in fact it isn't,
I mean the fact that I had a wicked
quote from derailed our show and it sort
of rings incredibly true given the
actuality,
the cosmic actuality,
not just our time,
but of all time said,
uh,
of someone brought up society and he
says,
society what?
The society.
It's a clearing in the forest.
You know,
that this will be reclaimed by nature.
We are in infinite space.
So your point about order and stability,
these things are always temporal.
The idea of ongoing stability in
limitless chaos when the actual code we
are being cradled by absolute chaos is,
it's an anathema and it's unsustainable.
It is unsustainable.
It can't continue,
but it will review.
But it doesn't mean you can't try and
achieve good things.
I mean,
there are two now.
It doesn't mean that there are two types
of political ideas have changed.
One is that you can actually seize
history and Tony or way,
which is sort of what Napoleon has tried
to do.
His great example.
The other is,
is that you,
you,
you understand that the world is chaos
and you see a moment where you can use
the chaos,
morally achieve what you want to do.
And that's the other way of changing the
world,
that it's about opportunity,
but you have to do that.
You have to have a picture in your mind
or what you are trying to get towards
what you think is good and then you
adjust as the chaos around you changes.
And,
but,
but we do know that we think this is it.
These ideologies are all.
I have to be sort of pretty reactive in
a sense though,
Adam,
because otherwise,
how do you fashion them?
Even if you talk about one of the most,
sort of a radical,
murderous,
but sort of a vivid narratives to emerge
like knit sort of 20th century fascism
is like,
that was a response to economic and
political conditions.
You can't just out of nowhere go,
let's do this thing.
The land is alive.
We are a folk and that's where it's
frightening change.
I mean that was a response to chaos in
the 19 twenties.
Um,
and,
and remember that they were socialists
to begin with finances.
Yeah,
national socialists and they had seen
the chaos at the market in America and
in Europe and they reacted against it
and said,
no,
we are going to organize this and we are
going to go towards this.
And it's very dangerous.
I mean,
the other argument is that all rhetoric
about revolution
at the moment is just rhetoric because
the experience of our generation of our
time is a century of revolutions that
went badly wrong.
Yeah.
And the last thing we want is one or
more of them.
And then actually what we were creating
in reaction is a very conservative
moment,
a counterrevolutionary moment.
That's what we're living through.
And it may go on for quite a long time.
And all arguments about revolutionary
change are just like quarterly behavior.
We do it,
but we don't really expect it's ever
going to happen.
This is a cynical view,
but maybe that's how history works.
You go through a period of intense
revolution which does change the world
and then you have a counter revolution
which which is actually born out of the
the,
the social classes that came out of
those revolutions that failed,
but it led to a new class breaking
through and now they want everything to
be stapled and that the argument about
what people like Mrs Thatcher and
President Reagan we're about is that a
new lower middle class which we're
confident rose up in the 19 seventies
and wanted its place in society and they
let me read.
Thatcher and Reagan left that class
through economically new labor,
let it through culturally and socially
and gave it confidence and now he wants
everything to stop and be stable and the
systems of management that we have got
him placed.
I'm talking about keeping everything
stable are a reflection of that class,
that path,
new classes,
desire for stability and we may be in
this for the longterm longterm,
but of course again,
these things,
these are quite isolated interests like
on a global level,
aren't they adam?
I mean,
or do you like.
Because when I'm.
When you take something that I think
ultimately there has to be a resource,
like any management of power,
the resource has to be sort of the
feelings of the people,
you know,
and of course people can be manipulated,
directed,
encouraged.
There's all sorts of things that can
happen to,
you know,
but we'll look at the way we consume,
look at the things we do,
the places we go,
what we were.
Obviously people's desires can be
management related and moved around the
question.
But like when you're talking about when
you sort of,
um,
when he becomes quite defined and
specific is it just did.
When you talk about like,
you know,
like sort of a,
a generation of people going through
batteries and then sort of is in or
whatever we would call it.
And now that makes sense to me as a
narrative.
It makes perfect sense.
But again,
we're talking like to wield such
incredible influence.
We're talking about a very small
phenomenon,
aren't we?
We're talking about sort of a class of
people in Western Europe.
You're living in America where we're
living in our bubble,
in history and in geography.
There are all sorts of other,
I mean the sad thing about our time is
there are all sorts of other things
happening outside our bubble,
but because we're so scared of change
and we're scared of looking outside and
we're scared of the future,
we don't really see them.
I always think the thing about our time,
which is sad,
is that we're a bit like,
you know when things go wrong in an
airplane or you're encouraged to adopt
what they call the brace position,
where you hunker down,
you're too frightened.
Jakarta window because you can see the
wind going up and down like that.
That's where we are at the moment.
We're,
we're refusing to look outside and see
another.
I do all my plain Jane is embrace
position since I've got on before they
bring the food.
Braise,
braise,
Mr.
it was still brochure.
Yeah.
We're embrace position at um,
we're looking at your phone.
Say,
look him.
I've never known anyone so keen to
manage and keep things stable.
Then Adam.
Curtis,
it's bloody you.
Every time a little bit of chaos comes
from the underneath,
from the upside down,
from the other world,
from the Nether region,
from the other place,
from the shadow lands.
You look down at your smartphone so
vehemently and aggressively.
Not Enough,
having met.
Don't like Lord Palmerston.
Do you know much about no pack course?
Are these appropriate?
A stove pipe pattern?
Oh No.
Lord Palmerston,
a biography by Russell brand based on
noise and one fact,
fact bearing his name.
I don't even know if he was.
Which part he was in liberals,
conservatives.
I don't even remember the names of Adam.
Thank you for coming in in here.
Pleasure.
You know I love you very much.
I do know that.
I wonder where you fit into all this in
your emotional life.
You are happier this some things
manifesting itself.
I don't think it's just pure narcissism,
but even if it is,
it's very powerful.
Too Real.
I wonder what's happening for you in the
world.
I was being serious that you.
You are a sort of the persona you have
created as a comedian is the arch
narcissistic or age you.
You play on that and you,
but you are self conscious about it and
in that sense you are,
what's the word and example of modern
social realism because everyone lives in
their heads these days.
Like you said,
they just do.
They don't live outside and most modern
novels or or the internal monologue
anyway,
you're an exponent's your you,
you,
you demonstrate that in three
dimensional space.
You,
you're very good at doing the,
bringing out the consciousness,
the way people live in their heads all
the time and you express it in a big,
what you would call comedic way.
Well,
it is objective.
Really.
Comedy is a discipline.
It's an art form.
You don't have to call it what you would
call and what you're keeping bumping up
against is what lies beyond that.
Yeah,
and is it religion or is that it?
Oh,
it is
these religion in the sense of like that
I in spite of being on a course of
religion and global politics where they
tell me,
this is not the definition,
but I believe that religion is where we
interface with the divine.
We're like,
this is where the thing.
I think I said this to you on the phone
the other day,
I said,
ultimately our capacity to understand
information will run out.
We're there is a limit to our
ability to understand information that
the information will not run out.
So at some point faith,
but isn't that what religion is it a
sense about?
It's about the acknowledgement of
everything we don't know and a story
that is based on face trying to make
sense of what we don't know.
That's right.
I've always thought that's what religion
was about.
Well apparently plus constellation in
the face of not knowing everything will.
It'd be nice.
I'd like.
So I think humility might be really good
for our society in the future and maybe
we've reached the limits of that
individualism,
but maybe we haven't.
Maybe this is it because we think of
trump as a sort of like a sort of a
gargoyle decoration on the priapic
thrusting hard on,
have an invalid journalistic and you
could look,
you could look at trump as the fag end
of that sort of individualism that
started back in the seventies.
It means Fagen.
English American isn't.
Yes,
I mean this.
Yeah.
The decade end of that,
that the sort of the counterculture
sitting around in the 19 seventies going
politics is shit,
man,
is it ends up with trump sort of
amazing,
you know,
and I can see he has as many roots in
the punk movement as he does in,
in the libertarian,
right wing of the sentences.
And he somehow a PR moment where all
those currents have come together and
are showing how to cade they've become.
Which means again,
we're waiting for something else.
Yeah,
I agree.
Well,
it's time for something else.
So I've been listening to the Russell
brand forecast with the Great Adam.
Curtis' hypernormalisation is available
and BBCI player,
if you're American,
you can probably get it on youtube by
now.
You Slippery Hill and the British
licensed payer paid for that and what
did you do?
He threw out tea into the harbor in
Boston.
Will enjoy their film.
Not on nod pendant.
Yeah.
That was russell brand under the skin.
I hope you enjoyed listening to me
interviewing Adam.
Cut and now an advert for.
What would you like?
Well,
dot tonight basket.
Get yourself a biscuit biscuits
available down at the shops there.
Which ones you're going to get that?
Well that's up to you,
but do get yourself a nice biscuit.
Not if you're worried about your white
though.
Make some changes.
Vegetables.
Have a vegetable.
I'd like to thank everyone that
contributed to this show.
Gary,
if he produced it,
Steven,
I'll either have been invaluable in
putting things together and then Jenny
may thin thank you.
All of you for your contributions are
those people that have come up with
ideas such as sitting still and being
nice.
Thank you.
Those guys subscribe.
If you like this podcast,
if you don't still subscribed because we
can still use you as capital and give it
a five star review because I bloated
sense of self importance is what gets me
through the night,
gets me through the night,
gets me through the night it gets me
through the night,
gets me through the night,
gets me through the night.
Okay.